[Music]
thank you
here we have um informed videos of toxic
women on Tick Tock and we'll uh review a
few of these let's start at the top
[Music]
okay bragging about the fact that you're
walking out of the house dress like a
stripper she belongs to the streets also
by the way this is a pretty new thing
like I've been going to gyms for I don't
know 25 years and it's only recently
where it became standard practice at the
gym for women to go in there not even
fully clothed it has not always been
that way which tells me it doesn't have
to be that way you're making a a choice
okay this one's good because this is
supposed to be actual footage of a
creepy guy at the gym doing something
totally inappropriate it's not just a
story being told later this is the the
actual thing let's all watch
probably some speak up
speak up when I'm about to cut I promise
I'm gonna speak up when I hop about to
cut I promise I'm gonna make Sheen got
lights cameras action but I promise that
I won't be seen he told me that she
loved me but I knew that make believe
but this ain't even about a show let me
catch you up to speed there's nobody can
we go back to that video there's no one
no one is looking at this check no one's
looking at you there is nobody there
everyone is minding their own business
they don't give a really yeah if
you're once again you go to the gym
you're wearing your underwear they're
bringing me people notice they're gonna
look over like oh look at that chicks in
her underwear okay but then they're
getting back to their own business
that's it they you want them to stare
you're desperate these people are heroes
in their own minds
she crosses her arms posing all tough
and no one is paying attention and
nobody cares uh but very heroic that's
struts female empowerment right there
have you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school your internet
service provider but actually stop
people from monitoring your online
activity you need to do what I do and
use expressvpn think about all the times
you use Wi-Fi at a coffee shop hotel or
even a friend's house without expressvpn
every site you visit can be logged by
the Admin of that Network that's still
true even when you're in incognito mode
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
your private online activity stays
private expressvpn is super easy to use
the app has one button you tap it to
connect and your browsing activity is
secure it's as simple as that stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Walsh YT use my Link at
expressvpn.com Walsh YT to get three
extra months free that's EXP resvpn.com
Walsh YT all right let's do one more so
I once had a guy walk up to me in the
middle of one of my sets while I was
working out and
on that day I think he's wearing either
a sports bra or crop top and leggings
pretty normal for me I had my headphones
in and he comes up to me and Taps on my
shoulder and the only thing he asked me
was he looked down at my chest and asked
me are those real this made me so
uncomfortable because not only did I
just get a breast augmentation I just
felt incredibly uncomfortable and it was
so uncalled for I did end up reporting
it to the front desk because this is
like straight up sexual harassment and
this guy was probably in his 70s so
creeps are at the gym and I highly
suggest that you report them so that yet
again she has to throw in the comment
about how he's in the 70s how is that
relevant to anything both but she wants
attention from certain types of men but
not a 70 year old man and so she wants
to be able to control that now the usual
caveats here that there's a 75 chance
that that didn't even happen but if it
did yeah the man shouldn't have made
that comment I would never make that
comment I would never say that to a
woman however you gotta breast
augmentation Asian you go work out in
public presumably in your underwear if
you're like all these other women at the
gym so people are going to notice that
part of your body it's what she deserves
if you don't want people to notice it
then why do you go to enormous effort to
call attention to it yourself you
literally augmented your breast you know
what the word augment means
[Music]
it's a little bit like if I were to go
out and buy a 250 000 sports car and
drive it around and then you know I pull
up somewhere and I park and somebody
walks up to me and they say wow how much
did you spend on that thing
smoke now that's rude that's a highly
inappropriate comment it's not again not
a question I would ever ask a guy riding
around in a in a nice car and yet also
the only reason to buy a car like that
and to drive it around is to advertise
your wealth so the statement that you're
making when you drive that car around is
hey look how much I spent on this car oh
look at me look at me I'm a girl so
they're gonna be people without
boundaries
who will take your message more to heart
you know more literally they're going to
say oh well you want me to notice that
so I do look at me noticing it this is
one of the many reasons why we should
have modesty in all areas of life that's
why it's one of many reasons why it's
preferable and again when we talk about
modesty that's not just something that
applies to women who are wearing their
underwear out in public it is also
immodest to flaunt your wealth you know
that's uh that's the kind of immodesty
might be more stereotypical of men
like it's raining on me okay but in all
these areas
you are really in a certain way you're
dehumanizing and you're objectifying
yourself you're calling attention to
something about yourself that is not
really you it's not your Humanity uh
you're trying to get people to notice
you in a kind of negative way once you
have intentionally attracted that kind
of attention
you're not always gonna like the result
everyone
wear your clothes when we go to the gym
let me
me everywhere
[Music]